si l'opposition se veut critique les
élus de guadeloupe vont te à l'encontre
du plan de déconfinement de matignon
alors que la plupart des écoles en
france métropolitaine vont rouvrir la
semaine prochaine le département ultra
marin se prononce pour que les siennes
ne le fasse pas avant septembre
cnet in basit vivant sepric a et
valentin carpentier quasiment huit
semaines que le lycée carnot de pointe à
pitre n'a pas vu le moindre élèves en
classe
confinés comme la france métropolitaine
la guadeloupe a fermé tous ses
établissements scolaires au début de la
crise sanitaire
une mise à l'arrêt qui va continuer
puisque les élus se sont prononcés pour
une reprise des cours en septembre et
non le 11 mai comme voulu par le
gouvernement d'edouard philippe pourtant
malgré ce report le lycée carnot se
prépare à un retour des élèves
nous avons de l hydro alcoolique
je signale que mes enseignants de
sciences physiques ont pris en fait de
l'hydro alcoolique donc on en a pour
l'établissement
mais non c'est sûr qu'on n'est faudrait
qu'on puisse en avoir un peu plus vous
permettre que dans chaque salle on
puisse gérer et puis organiser la grande
question c'est comment on va organiser
les salles pour que les élèves
il reste et qu' on ne peut pas faire
tourner les salles
donc voilà c'est un petit peu donc on
est en train de réfléchir sur tous ses
moyens ses protocoles dans tous les cas
si nous n'avons pas de sécurité garantie
nous ne pourrons pas ouvrir
mais je pense que c'est des choses qui
vont arriver au fur et à mesure 29
maires sur 32 ont voté pour cette motion
de report selon eux le retour en classe
pourra avoir lieu seulement lorsque
toutes les conditions sanitaires seront
respectés alors qu'à ce jour 152 cas et
13 mort du co vite 19 sont à déplorer
sur l'île de nombreux politiciens
estiment que ces conditions ne sont pas
réunies
c'est le cas de thierry à baby maire de
la commune de bouillante qui a voté en
faveur de cette motion que je n'ai
aucune garantie quant à la sécurité de
leur personnel
4 la sécurité des enfants qui
fréquenteront les écoles de bouillon
quant aux risques
face au risque d'une épaule 19 c'est
vrai qu'il ya une volonté de ma part
parce que les enfants retournent sur les
bancs de l'école peut vite possible
parce qu'effectivement sacré à dire les
ruptures part en tête si on n'a pas
atteint pourcentage de décrocher un prix
relativement important mais je considère
que si on fait le bilan de l'année
scolaire qui est en train de se tenir
les enfants n'auront pas eu bien du
talent beaucoup de cours en présentiel
donc il est important primordial même ce
que les enfants autrement plus
rapidement possible mais cela ne pas se
faire des profils conditions autres
principaux concernés les parents
d'élèves
tous sont d'accord pour repousser le
retour à l'école tant que les conditions
sanitaires ne sont pas optimales nous
exigeons que toutes les mesures soient
ni terre soit appliquée c'est à dire il
faut qu'il y ait des masques
il faut qu'il y ait des produits
hydro-alcooliques
il faut qu'il y en ait trois ya g
d'établissements scolaires il faut
effectivement qu'il y ait un dépistage
de tous ceux qui vont fréquenter les
établissements scolaires donc il faut
que les conditions soient réunies pour
la cantine scolaire pour le transport
scolaire et cetera et cetera
moi je pense que c'est une question je
dirai oui pour la rentrée dans un délai
bref est raisonnable mais aussi faut
prendre des précautions idoine je pense
qu'ils sont pas prêts ils sont pas du
tout prêts c'est que le président ne
seront pas du tout content quand ils
voient que parce que la maladie est
toujours là très fort et il s'est pas
rendu compte quand il a parlé du aux
concernant les trois villes dont les
mères ont décidé de la réouverture des
écoles le 11 mai le rectorat a préconisé
qu'elle est uniquement lieu le matin en
attendant un retour à la normale
415 établissements resteront fermés et
152 mille élèves devront patienter pour
reprendre les cours